hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar highly
multiplexed analysis
of mouse neural tissues i'm alexis cross
of labyrinth
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths and brought to
you by varanome biosystems
to learn more please visit their website
at varinombio.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
at the end of the presentation you may
also submit any technical issues here as
well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our first
speaker of the day chris streck
the director of applications at their
known biosystems
chris welcome you may now begin your
presentation
thank you very much and a warm thank you
to the entire lab roots team for
arranging this and
i appreciate all the attendees for
joining us today to hear
about the varanome solution for spatial
transcriptomic analysis
as well as dr hill bush's presentation
of the mouse tissues
again my name is chris drake and i'm
going to give you a very brief overview
of the varanome biosystem solution
as you have probably seen with the
advent of single cell sequencing
there has been a drive farther farther
in the direction to get higher
resolution and a higher level of detail
in analysis of individual tissues
and spatially resolved information has
become
has come to the forefront for that for
a lot of key investigations in fact in
2020
spatially resolved transcriptomics was
identified as the method of the year by
nature
method and we've seen a profound
improvement
um in the overall technologies
varenum biosystems is a fairly new
entrance
to this realm uh for those of you not
familiar
varanome emerged from a multi-year
collaboration between applied materials
and the genome institute of singapore
this combined some of the world's
leaders in engineering
and semiconductor and display technology
with a preeminent genomics research
facility
to develop new and powerful
life sciences tools and the formation
earlier this calendar year of verinome
biosystems
today i'm going to talk to you about the
overall
barenome imaging system which includes
an
instrumentation that allows us to run
very
highly multiplexed spatial rna analysis
so that biolog so that bio biologists
can now
look at subcellular resolution
and leverage the expertise of
the semiconductor semiconductor
industries best
experience and engineering
for the highest quality and fastest
results
as part of the varanum solution we've
built
a complete platform that includes
upfront
software tools to design your experiment
design your panels
track your experiment and run your up
your
and operate the actual instrumentation
additionally we've built
a advanced imaging system that allows
you to load your
samples into a flow cell uh and obtain
true single cell resolution even
subcellular detection
of might of messenger rna molecules
across a range of different tissues
we've designed this system to be very
easy to use with
very limited hands-on time and have true
walk-away
automation so that you can load your
samples
and then wait for the results to
be generated in terms of performance
we've spent a considerable amount of
time to provide the
highest quality data focusing in on some
of the newer
aspects um that are going to be key to
resolving individual rna molecules
within individual cells and we built
this system
to be high throughput to match current
lab workflows
lastly this is a bench top system so
that it can be
a true democratization of spatial
transcriptomics
additionally inter in addition to the
software reagents we also have
a primary analysis suite that allows you
to do
both statistical and visual
interpretation of our data
this is the portion of the presentation
that dr hillbusch will
go into detail but it allows immediate
actionable
interpretation of the data coming out of
the varanome system
a quick overview of the varenom platform
this is a picture of the instrument and
we currently have multiple instruments
in early access sites the system is
comprised of a flow cell
loading chamber all of the internal
components are comprised of the optics
for the actual detection and the
fluidics control
as well as a built-in optical um and
vibration damp
optical table for vibration dampening
we've designed the system for easy
access
for sample loading these
the individual reagents are loaded into
the instrument
in very simple rack formations and the
entire system is closed
for again true walk away automation
what we've built what we've designed
this tool
is to allow any researcher
whether they're working in traditional
pathology or molecular biology to
conduct very highly multiplexed analysis
uh for in-situ tissue characterization
this is includes pre-optimized
assays um and the panel content to allow
you to
have a single source for all of the
reagents that have been
developed and manufactured in a qc fully
qc'd and controlled environment
this allows you to target hundreds of
genes per run
and we've been able to demonstrate even
larger panels
additionally this platform is able to do
multi-ohmic capabilities with the
ability to add
protein targets immunofluorescent
protein targets to your
spatial rna analysis and then overlay
and combine that
that transcriptomic and protein analysis
to an
individual experiment lastly we've
developed a number
of different software analysis workflows
using the state-of-the-art
image analysis pipelines
use of traditional statistical analysis
for uh for data reduction or
statistical clustering of the gene
expression results
as well as a visualization tool to look
at those
combined results as an overlay onto the
tissue image
in terms of the content for our platform
we've developed a system that's highly
flexible
so we will have the ability we have the
ability to have fully customized panels
so that a researcher may access their
own account and design their uh their
list of experiments and design their
custom panels in a web-based portal
we are using our own proprietary design
for the
for the panel and the probe
creation and then you're also
able to track your projects through the
uh through the creation of your data and
analysis
in addition to the fully customizable
panel we have pre-validated panels for
both human
and mouse in a number of different
research areas including immunology
oncology developmental biology and
neurobiology
additionally we have the ability to
mix and match modules as the panels
will grow in size we will have basic
core panels
that will be comprised of the key usual
suspect genes within a certain
research area and then be able to mix
and match sub modules
so that you can provide off-the-shelf
pre-validated
custom panels using these pre
these subset modules this will include
specific immune cell markers to say give
better
uh characterization of say t cell
subtypes
or common tissue specific stromal or
oncology markers as well as defining
particular molecular pathways and
functions
the combination of three these three
strategies for panel design give
ultimate
flexibility for uh researchers to decide
design their experiments part of our
solution includes
a comprehensive software suite that
allows researchers to plan their
experiment
operate the instrumentation collect
their data
and analyze the results so on the left
hand side we see the instrument software
that allows
the researcher to set up their
experiments and detail the
sample specific information associated
with a particular run
we have a web application that allows
researchers to design their targets
or identify which panels they're using
and then we have an image analysis
pipeline that automatically does all of
the image
processing extracts the individual
features
and quantifies the rna molecules
then individual biologists can
take that data that was generated and
visualize those results
conduct the umap or other clustering
methods and develop cell
cell-based workflows that dr hill bush
will go
through in subsequent slides
i wanted to give a quick overview just
to highlight some of the ease-of-use
capabilities of this system
so the entire workflow is set up
within the instrument control software
so that you can
visualize your entire tissue identify
regions where you may want to
do higher levels of interrogation
and then be able to set up the routine
and track the project through the
through the different stages of data
collection on the imaging
processing side we've leveraged a lot of
the expertise
for image analysis to develop
novel methods and highly scalable
methods for image processing
including segmentation from the
segmentation point this is one of the
most important components
where we're using advanced algorithms to
define
the edges of the cells and quantify the
number of spots
in each individual cell this allows us
to get a large dynamic range
for genes expressed both at high and low
levels
and gives a true high level of
biological complexities
for high resolution of different cell
phenotyping
comparisons we've also implemented some
deep learning techniques for advanced
cell segmentation
that i that i'll show some brief
examples of to
tackle some of the greater challenges
with defining cell boundaries
and we're doing this all with the
expertise leveraged from
our experienced software and engineering
teams
to make this very fast and very scalable
some of the if as we compare some of the
segmentation algorithms and some of the
improvements that the verinom team has
conducted
traditional segmentation oftentimes
suffers from
a lot of problems such as
false negatives or false positives and
our deep learning
algorithm is actually now been able to
give higher
accuracy in terms of detection of
individual cells this includes
reduction of traditional false positives
and artifacts but also the ability to
look at
cells with a with different morphologies
and cells
sizes what you see on the left-hand side
is traditional segmentation and on the
right-hand side is the
varenom segmentation and you can see
very high resolution of cells of
different
sizes and different morphologies
additionally because there's going to be
a wide range of tissue types coming into
our platform
we've developed tools that allow
researchers to
customize or adjust the segmentation
capabilities within their individual
experiments
this allows researchers to set defaults
but then also adjust
the segmentation boundaries to identify
larger or smaller more complex
cell morphologies this is going to be
important to identify the maximum number
of spots
rna spots associated with any particular
cell region in this particular example
the light on the left hand side the
light blue was the
default boundary setting from the
algorithm and through
the hands-on and user-adjustable
boundaries
researchers can then tweak a number of
different
components to adjust those those
boundaries to result in larger
or more accurate cell cell areas
so i've tried to give a basic overview
of the over of the system
but i'd like to highlight a couple of
the different application areas where
we're focused
so one of the key applications that was
demonstrated at this year's agvt
conference by one of our researchers
research collaborators at the genome
institute of singapore
was to look at organoids at subcellular
resolution looking at anywhere from 5
000 to 50 000 cells per tissue and as
as high as 547 genes this is a very
exciting talk that demonstrated
the true biological utility of the
varanome platform
additionally through our collaborators
we've got
a number of different experiments
building off of that
initial uh some of the initial technical
development
not just with the human brain organoid
but also
with a considerable amount of mouse
neural models as well as human brain
tissues
what i'm seeing here on the in the two
middle
what i'm showing here in the two middle
panels represent some of the mouse
neuro tissues that dr hill bush will go
through but also on the right hand side
the human brain tissue
that represents both the rna as well as
protein markers simultaneously captured
in the experiment
additionally through our collaborations
we're working with a number of different
io researchers
to profile oncology samples and get the
true heterogeneity
associated with with the tumor micro
environment lastly i want to finish with
just a couple notes
about uh varanome as a company so
at agbt this year so in march of uh 2021
we announced uh the formation of the
company
and specifically talked about our early
access placements
that have been going on for quite some
time up until this point we have been
quietly working on a number of different
pilot studies through our service
program
and are expanding that capabilities
through a variety of different
manner manners additionally
last month in or last month
in june of 2021 we announced a
co-development partnership with portal
biosciences
this is to implement a second generation
assay for
to allow us to interrogate challenging
samples
such as ffpe compatibility as well as
get higher resolution
of your rna targets including splice
junctions
and all the way down to single
nucleotide
resolution lastly uh
as we've described in previous press
releases we
are in the process of our expanded
beta program and working towards
commercial commercialization
this includes a complete infrastructure
to provide
fully developed q seed and robustly
manufactured reagents
software and instrumentation
so hopefully today i've been able to
give you a brief overview of the system
we'll end the presentation with
answering questions and we'll provide
some additional information on how to
get in touch
with the verinome team and get
additional detail
with that i'd like to turn it over to
brian
thank you chris for that presentation
i'd like to introduce our second speaker
of the day
dr brian hilbush director of digital
solutions at barenome biosystems
brian welcome you may now begin
your presentation
okay great hello this is brian hobash
from varyknown biosystems
in this part of the webinar i'm going to
talk about highly multiplexed analysis
of mouse neural tissues
we are developing a set of robust
applications for neuroscience research
and i'm going to show you examples of
our data that highlights
the strengths and features of our system
in the start just a little background on
neuroscience you know
neuroscience is a highly integrated
discipline and for the past hundred
years
has really involved uh both neuroanatomy
neurophysiology and genetics
to get to an understanding of nerve
function in the last couple of decades
it's really
been computational methods and genomics
that has
really propelled neuroscience forward
and so pheronom
we've produced a highly multiplex
spatialomic system
that i think is going to really
celebrate research and i'm going to show
you that
through a series of examples now
one of the things that we have done with
the system as chris described
is to build uh multiplex panels that
really can address
a number of experimental paradigms and
and
evaluations in neuroscience
these key applications include you know
looking at cellular responses to drugs
experimental perturbations crispr
screens
and other aspects of pathobiology
uh includes be able being able to look
at
spatial dynamics and do careful pattern
detection across
you know brain sub regions and then
finally
we're looking at a lot of applications
that involve
doing cellular phenotyping
transcriptional phenotyping and just
evaluating cell states
as well as neural anatomical mapping of
cell types
so the burnham system generates uh
beautiful data for this
we have analytics that are tightly
integrated to the data types that are
being
produced and required for these types of
analyses
and they lead really straight to
biological insights as
sort of defined on the right side of
this slide
the panels that we have designed the
first one that we did was to
really cover uh synaptic function and
have just general markers for neuronal
and glial
cells in the mouse brain
uh so these were heavily weighted
towards neurotransmitter receptors
neuropeptide receptors
uh a variety of ion channels as well as
a whole array of uh
transporters in the solute carrier
family
so those uh have been very useful in
being able to
do some initial explorations from r d uh
sort of standpoint
and we've now built a new panel that we
call mouse neuro b2
which is a lot more balanced and has a
much wider variety of
cell type specific markers as well as
universal markers
of a range of cell types as indicated
here on the left
and then those cover a variety of
you know biological processes and uh
ability to
kind of sort of surveil pathological
states
uh through this panel composition so
those
i'm going to show you mainly examples uh
in this webinar
around the neuro b2 data
panel one of the things that really
drives the system is our
integrated informatics that we have
built we have
tools that are designed to
really walk an investigator through
three different workflows
one that's simply taking data uh sort of
a gene-centric view
driving a menu of genes that are on the
panel
doing quality control checks and being
able to explore
the data quite interactively in the
visualization screen
we then have a another workflow that
allows
initial explorations of patterns and to
do some number crunching around
you know correlation um and sort of
binning and looking at you know spatial
networks
and then finally we've got a a real
unique
workflow designed around single cell
based clustering that we can do really
fine expression signature analysis
uh produce a variety of plots to look at
the data such as disney and
umap as well as being able to sort of
drill down and do some fine
filtering in selection as needed
so one of the starting points i think
for showing you the power of the system
is to
give you some examples from the mouse
cerebellum
in which we have done uh a preliminary
survey
um this really gives you a feel i think
for how sensitive the transcription
detection is
of the ability of us to really pull out
uh
highly specific cells with uh the
first panel that we've built and then to
really
give you a feel for just sort of the
multiplex visualization
that these panels provide combined with
the the software
and you'll see the patterns come out so
the bottom left there is just a
an image from the mouse uh mouse brain
from the uh
allen brain atlas showing you um kind of
the region of the cerebellum that we
section and we're gonna look at uh data
through uh
sagittal sections
for those of you who are that aren't
familiar with the cerebellum it's a very
simple structure very beautiful
it has a simple three layer structure
the top layer pictured on the left and
the right
are the molecular layer
where the petition cells extend their
processes
out into and are contacted by a variety
of
cell types including the granule cell
climbing fibers as well as
interacting with acid and cellulite
cells in that layer
induced cell layer has both purkinje
cells as well as astrocytes like
the berman glia and then also the
granule cell layers
densely packed with granule cell neurons
and other
support cells so the picture on the
right
shows you sort of the first glimpse of
just how sensitive our technology is if
you can look at
the uh sort of the turquoise um overlay
you'll see
the inositol triphosphate receptor
uh highlighting uh high rna expression
way out in
dendrites in the imperfection neurons
that are projecting out into
into molecular layer this is really one
of the most striking things we've seen
um in this analysis of the sale of
balance
so we have a number of examples to kind
of give you a little bit more on you
know sort of
how we're able to get this resolution um
and this is clearly uh
sub sailor because you're looking at you
know processes that are extending out
that are probably some micron
in size just a bigger
blow-off picture of this for you uh on
the left-hand side you can see
provincial neurons
dotted with that rna expression
and you'll see a few empty spots along
the way there
and on the lower left you can see that
they're actually occupied by the birdman
glia
which are expressing high levels of this
transporter
so that's kind of a beautiful example of
kind of the exquisite uh cell type
specificity of these markers as well as
the ability
of the system to provide you very high
resolution
uh imaging uh across these cells
and on the right is just another another
view
of these two um going into
other cell types and other molecular
classes looking at
glutamate receptors such as the
metabotrophic glutamate receptor
you can see uh it's very highly
expressed in the granule cell layer
much lower in the molecular layer
in contrast to the ampa receptor degree
of four which is
primarily expressed out in the molecular
layer so just a couple
of pretty pictures to show you sort of
um
what we're seeing as we look through
just a couple of markers in the
cerebellum
a couple of other examples are a
potassium channel a delayed rectifier
that's expressed looks like mainly in
basket cell and
stella cells gives you a really nice
view of
sort of how they're distributed out of
the molecular layer and then finally in
white matter regions you can see
clearly myelin basic protein
as well as aquaporin for astrocytes
being distributed out out in the
fringes there now one of the
really nice things that what you can do
is you can move from visualization right
into
expression correlation analysis and here
i'm just showing you
some data from looking at a subset of
the receptors
how that we've gone this panel
and you can see right away that there is
you know high correlation of
spatial expression of a number of gaba
receptors including
gaba b you know one and two along with
the ip3 receptor and also
the serotonin one of the serotonin
receptors so that's
really um a very quick and easy way of
looking at um expression profiling sort
of at
you know kind of a co-expression sort of
level
um of course the system can do a lot
more than that one of the powerful
things that
i think the system provides is the
ability to
generate molecular signatures and
beautiful expression maps
from really what we've seen now are a
variety of structures
that are quite diverse across the brain
including hippocampus
the cortex which are which is quite
layered
as well as midbrain hindbrain and other
regions
in the mouse cns that are you know much
less structured but have
you know underlying structure of the
nuclei and we'll see some examples in a
minute here
but this slide is just showing you
examples of the signatures that
are generated from these structures the
top part
is the signature off of the v1 panel
for this region on the left and you can
see the array of markers and on the
bottom is the
molecular signatures from the the v2
panel
and there you can see that right away
the the cluster analysis
and the panel is able to discriminate
the number of neuronal cell types
glutamate neurons versus gabaergic
interneurons
a couple of oligodendrocyte classes
astrocytes
as well as microglia endothelial and
another
couple of subclasses of oligodendrocyte
and neurons
so right away with the panels
we're able to get really clear
distinctions on cell type just by
looking at
the detection rate which is indicated by
uh the strength of those
those dots so the smaller dots indicate
lesser expression
and a lower detection rate on a per
cluster basis versus
really large dots which are cells that
have
very high detection rates
there's also you're looking at disease
scores as well on
the bar on the right you've got z-scores
uh just
distributed from negative to positive
and you can see
you know cluster representation the
variance that
helps to find those clusters using that
z-score information
all that information can be downloaded
into excel spreadsheets if need be or
put into other programs
so yeah the export of general data is
quite simple it looks just like single
cell data so you can export it into
programs like serat this is a little bit
of data from our mouse dry item example
here i'm just showing you sort of the
basic steps that you can take in syrah
to go from
normalizing scale data to principal
components analysis
and then you can generate heat maps as
shown on the top there for the
different principle components and these
cell by gene matrices
and then also you can you know generate
disney and umap plots and that
analysis package as well in addition to
getting
sort of biomarker statistics off of you
know the
most highly represented genes your
particular sample
with the neural v2 panel i think one of
the most beautiful things is that we can
really begin to see a much broader
clustering of
these markers across you know your
analysis um here i'm just showing you an
array of
marker types and coexpression patterns
ranging from the neuronal types at the
top there glutamatergic gabaergic and
just general neuronal universal markers
all the way down through much
more subtle classes like the neural stem
cells in the middle
uh opc's olympia sites and so forth so
this panel really is equipped with a
range of tools
to interrogate neuronal systems
and the software itself can then provide
alternative views spatial maps
and and ways to do sort of correlation
analysis
one of the things that we have done is
just to simply look at the data
and see what it tells us and one of the
things that is striking to me
is that given these panels and the the
clustering tools
one can actually begin to see
substructures
in the brain that are sort of only
evident by
sort of careful neuro anatomical mapping
so so with the the cell typing ability
and the clustering you can see
subdivisions in the
thalamus quite clearly as indicated on
the left-hand panel there
so hippocampus is obvious uh the
thalamus not quite as obvious but you
can see
clearly you know the right next to the
lateral ventricle sort of fiber tracks
going through
the thalamus right next to the reticular
nucleus
and then a number of areas in the
thalamus that are projection neurons
that are glutamatergic
and that's sort of the uh some defining
parts of the thalamus there
on the right hand side um i just pick
one example of a
of one gene that tends to highlight
mostly the glutamatergic neurons
and gives you a nice definition of the
thalamic nuclei and that's vipr1
the receptor for the biozoactive
intestinal peptide
and you can see down on the lower right
hand corner just sort of the
strength of expression of that
particular rna
in the thalamus versus other other brain
regions
we look up a little bit more closely uh
what's really interesting is that
the system is able to produce
some insights around sort of sub-regions
that have not really been molecularly
defined before
uh so on the left-hand panel you're
seeing
clusters of gabaergic neurons
highlighted in white there
you see some out streaming out there on
the cortex a little bit in
specific subiculum and then down on the
lower part of that left-hand panel
you'll see the reticular
nucleus on the left and the right-hand
side the vipers is there for reference
in the middle
i found genes such as fgf1 that
highlight the reticular nucleus pretty
well as well as a glutamate receptor
grip3 that's known to be expressed quite
highly there
on the right we're seeing some kind of
novel findings with
markers such as cd6 and then also
a couple of other genes itg a7 cdk6
as well as some kinases that we've
identified in doing the analysis so
there's a
small um breakdown of of this particular
region into very small
sub sub regions that do or take
different inputs
and provide um you know signals that are
used to regulate the thalamus through um
gabaergic output negative output um and
so this is probably indicating there's a
one of these regions that's highlighting
uh being highlighted by this molecular
signature so that's just a
interesting observation to show you sort
of the power of the system
another thing that we spent time on is
to
just demonstrate that we can get high
resolution cell type specificity
of markers that are of importance in
doing cell typing analyses
in this example we're looking at the
hypothalamus and in particular
i've zoomed in on a region of the
hypothalamus known as the lateral
hypothalamic area
it has both glutamatergic and gabaergic
cell types that are well known and
actually there's a
quite a number of subtypes of those as
well
so if you start in the upper left-hand
corner that's kind of a higher
you know lower level view sorry of um
the region that was imaged
uh if we cluster that and get uh
clusters on the lower left-hand side
um a little left-hand panel and then
move over
to the kind of the panel in the middle
there that's highlighting the the two
different
neuronal types we can actually do some
quantitation of of how well the markers
are performing
just by counting uh in this case a few
hundred cells
in investigating uh sensitivity and
specificity
um on the right hand side um i've
counted the
the cells for two markers for
glutamate neurons as well as for the
gaba neurons and you can see the
sensitivity
for the synaptic vesicle transporters
you know is quite good
in the mid 80s and then for
the gabaergic neurons of the
synthesizing enzyme god too is is super
high with almost a hundred percent you
know sensitivity or recall
so that's really a really interesting
finding uh
you know i think one of the things that
gives us a lot of confidence around
being able to use these as markers kind
of throughout the brain
we've also done these sorts of
investigations in the
human cerebral cortex and this is just
again looking at the
the gabaergic and glutamatergic neurons
highlighting the fact that you can
discriminate these cell types
uh you know quite easily in the brain
and i'm showing you an overlay
that the system has to just really
display both protein markers as well as
the rna markers the protein markers
we're showing here our
new end for neurons in green and then
the astrocytes you can see clearly in
blue
so it really looks like we're doing
quite well in terms of
how how clearly localized the expression
patterns are
uh it's really um
one of the most interesting things about
the system is that we can we can
really turn this into a multi-omic tool
uh
again just doing a small bit of analysis
on the human
cerebral cortex you can see on the
um on these slides here that
neurons the neuronal clusters are
highlighted in blue
uh the astrocytes in red and you can see
on the left sort of the
immunofluorescence with gfap which is a
strong astrocyte marker
and you can see they uh the red
groupings are rna based markers that are
overlying most of the ester sites
blue is for the neurons so a little bit
higher higher resolution view
of uh of that on the right uh so those
are sort of
some of those features that we've got
with uh
you know analyzing uh neuronal types uh
in
particularly in the mouse brain and this
is really uh
sort of giving you sort of a feel for
just what the system can do it really
gives you a
validated high-resolution spatial
platform really a variety of
neuroscience applications
shown down below there the data that's
generated
there really is that single cell
resolution and you can actively resolve
you know brain region patterning and
dive into you know the complexity of
what's happening in the nervous system
and really evaluate the heterogeneity
uh the panel designs that we're working
on we offer a powerful solution for
doing you know cellular phenotyping
across a range of models uh in neural
development and also the multinomic
analysis capabilities so the
you know the experiments that uh ones
most focused on in neuroscience today
on the left there we can generate the
data
we have the analysis tools to quickly
work with you know our platform's data
and then generate the insights
kind of listed there on the right so
that's a quick run
run through of the mouse brain data
and i wanted to thank the entire
paranormal biosystems team
which is down a tremendous amount of
work and just producing the instrument
uh producing the data and also all the
beautiful analysis tools
with that um i'm going to leave you with
uh
just a request to check out our social
media sites
you know follow us on twitter and and
linkedin
and now i'm going to take some questions
you know from the audience at the end of
the webinar thank you
you chris and and brian for your
informative presentations
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
is
your data with glutamate and gaba
markers for discriminating neuronal
types showed impressive sensitivity and
specificity
in the cortex and hypothalamus do you
have data on other markers that perform
as well
hi thanks alexis yes we do uh we've
generated analyzed and validated
probably over 50
cell type specific markers the
validation has been done using uh
examination of cell cellular and spatial
expression patterns and by analyzing
their performance uh in clustering
sort of experiments so these um include
additional neuronal cell type markers
and cortex
striatum thalamus and other regions and
we also have a series of excellent
markers for oligodendrocytes
subtypes of oligos microglia
both activated and just homeostatic as
well as endothelial cells and astrocytes
we also have these for both human and
mouse panels
great thank you so much brian so our
next question
uh looks like it is a two-part question
is the system doing the imaging
or do you need an outside imager
hi sure so the system
is entirely self-contained in the
instrument so the imager and the
microfluidics are all contained in a
single
uh benchtop system so you don't need a
a separate instrument to do the
chemistry
great thank you chris uh we're going to
go back to brian for this next question
is varinum cell workflow uh what tools
do you have to track cell type
heterogeneity within
brain regions and across regions
yeah that's a really great question on
heterogeneity i think
you know since we have the single cell
resolution we can examine the entire
cell by gene matrix and determine
subsets of cells of interest and look at
their expression patterns
now from the matrix you can look at
expression signatures or normalized
expression
values these can be compared for cells
that are adjacent or within the same
brain region or even across you know
different regions
since we have the spatial information we
can actually select cells or regions
from the image
and examine heterogeneity that way at a
very high level of resolution
and do so around say neurogenic plaques
or
areas of inflammation so it's a lot of
great tools for that
great thank you our next question in the
phthalo
reticular nucleus example you showed
evidence of a sub-region
specific signature have you been able to
see
other potentially novel signatures
across other brain regions
yeah again uh you know this is being
used
pretty well as a discovery tool and
we've been able to detect novel
signatures
you know across other brain regions
we're looking at uh
really interesting results in sub
regions of the cortex the hindbrain
thalamus where we're seeing really novel
patterns and expression signatures and
the data
you know suggest potentially new
cellular subclasses or at least novel
functional states that are unique and
again since we have both
quantitative differences in expression
and spatial patterns we don't
necessarily have to rely just on solely
on the numbers like you would do in a
single cell
sequencing type experiment
thank you so much and i do want to
remind our audience we've gotten
so many great questions in today any
questions we are unable to get to
today we'll answer via email with the
email address that you use to register
for today's event
so our next question can your cell
segmentation parameters be adjusted
and optimized by the user
yeah i can take that one um yes indeed i
mean the
cell segmentation component
prior to looking at the data users
are going to have access to uh an
application where they can select
a type of algorithm the training model
and also parameters such as
dilation memory dilation to optimize
performance so our r d
team is building and validating uh
segmentation algorithms
and uh currently we're out performing
segmentation algorithms such as cell
pose and we're going to continue to
you know sort of improve on our deep
learning approach with nuclear and
cell boundary markers so we've got a lot
of activity in that area
we think we're probably at the forefront
great thank you so much now i believe
this may have been mentioned in the
presentation but just
to confirm can this be used on human
brain tissue
oh yeah yes we're currently doing a lot
of i'm sorry go ahead
right yeah absolutely i mean we've got
a lot of applications coming in on the
human brain and we're
actively generating data on that right
now
yeah and one of the panels one of the
experiments that i showed in the early
presentation was
we didn't do a deeper dive but we'll be
uh doing a follow-up webinar on the
human tissues
but one of the panels that i
demonstrated was a highly multiplex rna
target plus
uh code detection of a number of
different uh proteins in a un
and a couple of other key uh markers so
uh we're we're quite a bit of our early
collaborations
are in the human neural realm
thank you gentlemen both for your
answers now how does the algorithm
produce higher accuracy
in segmentation
chris do you want to handle that do you
want me to address that
uh sure so um i'll i'll let you handle
the technical component
um another part of our webinar series is
going to be walking through
our image analysis process including the
segmentation results
and what we've been doing is
benchmarking
our algorithm to some of the um
open source or published segmentation
algorithms out there
so with that i'll let brian
tackle the next step yeah i mean i think
most of the
you know superior performance we're
getting comes from our deep learning
framework
so we use a compilation of neural net
and some other tricks to sort of really
eat the highest performance out and we
have um really good annotation
data sets uh with which we can do the uh
the training and also the benchmarking
so yeah we've got
a lot of tools for that
great thank you gentlemen we've got time
for a couple more questions so our next
question
is do you clear the tissue
sure that's a that's a great question a
lot of the
early work that we've been doing uh with
our collaborators is to bring in a host
of different tissue types
uh different qualities that sort of
thing as you probably know
um different tissues will have varying
levels of autofluorescence
or very varying levels of
overall background noise and so we've
developed a number of different sample
prep protocols
and techniques so some methods we some
particular tissues the clearing is not
required
other avenues other tissue sources
we have been working on implementation
of such methods it really comes down to
characterizing and providing
our customers with a decision tree to
help them understand which path they
want to follow
thank you chris and um this i believe
this question is going to go to brian so
can you describe the time it takes to go
from image generation to data analysis
yeah sure uh there are two stages really
to get
analysis ready data the first is
to take a reasonably sized region of
interest say
hippocampus and thalamus and then take
that image and perform calibration
registration and decoding
plus the cell segmentation so all that
preprocessing
steps all those steps take probably
somewhere in the range of one to three
hours
the second stage is just simply loading
the processed image file
into the veriscape browser the file is
usually read in and ready in a few
minutes
analysis can be undertaken immediately
there's really
very little data preparation and
downtime and the desktop application
will do and process uh you know
algorithms to produce you know disney
plots and clustering and imaging
image rendering uh almost in near real
time for most of that so that's the
sort of overall time frame going from uh
sort of
imaging on the system to analysis
probably within you know three to four
hours
great thank you so much and chris i
believe you may have had a
comment for the audience real quick sure
sure so we've got a number of questions
asking about the overall throughput
image now
um image area as well as a sense the
sensitivity of detection so rather than
answering each one of them i might just
tackle them all uh in
in one answer uh because there's a lot
of repeat questions
um so in terms of the sensitivity we're
on par with
single molecule detection associated
with uh standard fsm
fish so the the technology is uh
is uniquely sensitive for detection of
individual molecules but
um as we know through the development
there's also
requires to get high quality data that
also requires being able to discern
individual rnas next to each other and
so that's really where the technical
team has
shown and developed a very high quality
product
um in terms of the plexity of the panels
we're working in typically in the
hundreds uh currently we've demonstrated
higher
uh but we're typically in that um that
sweet spot for most experiments uh
these days and then on the image uh the
image area
as you saw from the uh from one of my
slides we've got the whole
uh we're starting with pieces of tissue
um i think you could have visualized
pretty much the entire human
or sorry a mouse the entire mouse brain
and then
the overall area that you're imaging is
going to be dependent on how much you
want to see so that's tunable
to the researcher and the number of
plexi that you're looking at and so
um it's more of a matrix uh for how long
an experimental
uh an experimental an experiment will
take
based on those parameters so it's kind
of a
there's a there's not a straightforward
um this is the one size fits all type of
run it's tunable to your particular
experiments
um and i'd uh recommend anyone who's
interested in those uh
in additional details we're happy to
set up answer those questions in
individual calls or follow-up sessions
and alexis back to you for other
questions
great thank you so much chris looks like
we have time for maybe one
maybe two more questions for here today
so and
now brian chris i believe this is going
to be a question for both of you and it
is a two-part question
how long does the essay take and the
second portion
is how long does the analysis take
sure so the overall experiment requires
a
fairly short amount of time hands-on
time
to set up the individual assay so
once your tissues have been sectioned
onto our slide
the overall bench time is
really a a very quick process
uh so there's some hybridization steps
once once the flow cell is set
onto the instrument the instrument runs
um all of that portion is automated
uh so that our instrument runs can be
anywhere from
just a couple a few hours to over eight
hours so it's a pretty rapid turnaround
in terms of the um total time
additionally
multiple samples can be prepped at the
same time
uh so that if you wanted to set up uh
multiple runs in serial uh your bench
time
can actually be your bench time for
sample prep is actually a parallel
process to
drastically reduce the the typical
workflow
time in terms of the analysis i'll let
brian handle that
question yeah the analysis time is
really pretty rapid i think within
15 to 20 minutes you can probably get
you know cluster visualization
disney plots um looking at
so by gene matrix numbers and doing
a lot of visual inspection of you know
molecular maps
and that sort of thing and looking at
correlation data uh
you know very very very quickly um you
know offline you could probably then
download the data
into other you know statistical analysis
packages and do
whatever you would like so you know
you're actually getting to data very
very quickly on the system with the
tools that we've already built in
great thank you so much brian and chris
for answering all of these amazing
questions
do you have any final comments for our
audience chris i'll go ahead and start
with you
uh yes thank you very much for hosting
this and
and being our sherpa through the
question and answer series and i'd like
to thank the audience for joining us
today
again we're happy to answer any
additional questions if you'd like
additional information please visit us
at
veronembio.com or in or send us an email
at info
verydomebio.com where we'll be happy to
follow up
additionally we've got a series of
webinars that we'll be posting
on our website as well so please join us
again to see
additional biological insights as well
as additional details on the chemistry
the assay
uh and the overall system
yeah thank you all and then oh sorry go
ahead brian
i just want to say thanks to the
audience and you know we'd love to be in
contact with anyone that has
interest in neuroscience applications
and that you know what the platform can
do for you
great thank you again chris and brian
for your time today
and for your important research we would
also like to thank labberts
and our sponsor varanome bias system for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i would like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions that we did not have time for
today
and those to submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
our speakers
via the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have
who may have missed today's live event
until next time
bye bye everyone